So since fractions are just division,
we can convert a fraction to a decimal
by performing that division.
Let's take an easy one, one half.
This is the same thing
as 1 divided by 2.
This might be a good time to remind
you that 1 is the same thing
as 1.0 which is also
the same thing as 1.00,
which is also the same thing as 1.000.
Adding more 0's after the decimal point
here does not change the value of 1.
It just tells us a more
precise value for 1.
So in order to be more precise and to
make division here a little more easy,
I'm going to add a few
extra trailing 0s here.
And by adding these extra
0s after the decimal point,
I still have not changed the value of 1.
I'm just being more precise.
All right, on with the division.
2 goes into 1 0 times.
Now let's make sure that we put
our decimal point that's here,
we'll also put it up here.
So now how many times
does 2 go into 10 here?
It should go in 5 times.
2 times 5 is 10.
And when we subtract, we get 0.
And there we go, we have 0 here,
so 0.5 is our answer.
One-half is the same thing as 0.5.
Now you give it a shot.
What is three-fifths as a decimal?
Enter your answer here.